[Musik]
ja herzlich willkommen resultiert daraus
eine sprechstunde der nacht
jetzt mal ehrlich wie ist das bei ihnen
leben sie ganz langweilig oder führen
auch sie ein doppelleben mit einem
zweiten partner einem zweiten beruf
einer geheimen leidenschaft oder werden
sie vielleicht ganz gerne ja ein
doppeltes leben das klingt gut sicher
besser als ein halbes leben aber jetzt
mal ehrlich ist das nicht vor allem
furchtbar anstrengend ein doppeltes
leben
wir sprechen jetzt gleich mit menschen
die ein doppelleben führen uns mit dem
inhaber einer alle die agentur der ihnen
das perfekte alibi verschafft wenn sie
uns brauchen lustgewinn entfremden
bänden
sie führen manchmal über jahre hinweg
ein doppelleben
die affäre wird verheimlicht damit in
der beziehung alles bleibt wie es ist
die moral ist sie schuld am doppelleben
die angst aufzufliegen verdirbt sie uns
das doppelleben
sein doppelleben findet im studio einer
domina stadt eine ganz eigene welt von
der selbst der beste freund nichts
wissen darf er hat die welt getäuscht
und belogen
der deutsche reporter class re lucius
hat geschichten und personen erfunden
und preisgekrönte reportagen daraus
erschaffen enttarnt hat ihn ein kollege
das doppelleben eines hochstaplers mehr
besser wichtiger sein als das eigene
leben jeher geben würde
menschen die ihr leben um eine lüge oder
illusion herum bauen faszinieren und
irritierend zugleich sie gehen
verbotenen leidenschaften nach täuschen
sich selbst und andere
[Musik]
sie gefangen im körper eines mannes
die große befreiung in der einsamkeit
als frau unterwegs
amorbach aus frose entweder williams
offen ich sehe oder reststoffe müssen
mit deren angst wie wir die ganztag die
mini sperrt busch und jetzt rasch user
[Musik]
da ist der katholische priester der
seiner berufung folgt und gleichzeitig
heimlich frau und kinder hat der eine
lebensentwurf von der gesellschaft
akzeptiert der andere verboten verpönt
und deshalb geheim gehalten
der zölibat als fassade die familie als
geheime existenz wenn es erst einmal da
ist das geheime leben wird man es nur
schwer wieder los
[Musik]
der hochstapler der als falscher arzt
patienten behandelt der spielsüchtige
der seine sucht verheimlicht die
wissenschaftlerin die ihre
forschungsarbeit fälscht der
vermeintliche kz-überlebende der eine
frei erfundene holocaust autobiografie
schrieb
auch er führte lange ein doppelleben
pascal erlachner schwuler spitzen
schiedsrichter im fußball
schwul in einer der letzten bastionen
traditioneller
männlichkeitsvorstellungen wer bin ich
eigentlich nur ein einziger oder haben
wir alle verschiedene identitäten ist
das doppelleben der preis einer
gesellschaft die nicht alles zulässt ist
es ausdruck radikaler freiheit und was
geschieht wenn wir ausbrechen und unsere
diversen identitäten schamlos ausleben
was dann
sind wir dann uns selbst
[Musik]
ja und jetzt sitzt er beim hier mir
gegenüber pascal erlachner sie haben
sich vor zwei jahren als homosexuell
geoutet als erster im schweizer
spitzenfußball im profifußball
das braucht mut woher hatten sie diesen
mut also bei mir hat eigentlich jedes
outing kommt sehr viel mut gebraucht es
hat angefangen als ich 30 wurde habe ich
mich bei meinen eltern mit einem sms
geoutet und ich konnte dieses
doppelleben einfach nicht mehr führen
das war für mich zu anstrengend ich war
zu oft zu traurig und ja dann war ein
großer stein der da vom herzen gefallen
ist
dann kam jedes weitere coming-out das
zweite für mich ganz wichtiger war bei
meinem großvater der auch in einer
anderen generation aufgewachsen ist und
auch das war wunderschön wir wer mich in
die arme genommen hat und gesagt hat du
bist genau gleich mein pascal wie du es
auch vorher warst und auch das hat sehr
viel mut gebraucht und nach einer
gewissen zeit habe ich dann auch im
fußball das gefühl gehabt jetzt möchte
ich einfach so sein wie ich bin ich
möchte meinen partner ins spiel nehmen
können
ich muss mich nicht mehr verstecken und
ja ich hab mich dann auch im fussball
geerntet sie hat dieses versteckspiel
dieses doppelleben ausgesehen bei ihm
dass sie über mehrere jahre geführt
haben
also zuerst war es ein doppel in das ich
mich hier selber nicht akzeptieren
konnte
ich habe immer das gefühl gehabt das
kommt dann schon noch einmal ich stehe
dann schon einmal noch auf frauen was
sie haben sich selbst auch belogen nicht
nur die hre am anfang einer und das war
sehr sehr anstrengen also ich hatte mich
immer wieder zu männern hingezogen
gefühlt aber ich habe das nicht
zugestanden
ich habe es auch mit frauen probiert und
einfach gemerkt dass das geht nicht das
ist nicht das was ich was ich fühle das
was also das ist nicht der pascal er ja
gerne frei sein möchte uns einfach
freundlich fröhlich und glücklich sein
möchte und ja dieses doppelleben auch
sehr anstrengend und ich wollte mich
dann halt auch mit männern treffen und
dann hast du zum alten angst dass sich
jemand erkennt wenn du dich irgendwo mit
jemandem trifft und ganz normal etwas
trinkt dann ja aufzufliegen und
irgendwie dass die leute merken
und er steht auf männer und das war
wirklich sehr sehr anstrengend und eben
auch traurig für mich
sie hatte nach zwei handys
zwischenzeitlich genauso ich hatte
einfach das gefühl dass wir nicht dann
mit meinem freund schreibe das dafür da
niemand sehen und dann hatte ich ein
zweites handy das habe ich dann haut
wirklich nur dann eingeschaltet wenn ich
bei uns alleine war eines niemand
gesehen habt und ja das auch immer so
ein gefühl du wirst beobachtet du machst
etwas voraus und wenn ich jetzt heute
daran zurückdenke ist es irgendwie ganz
komisch aber das gehört einfach zu
dieser zeit wo ich selber noch nicht zu
mir stehen konnte wie fühlt sich das an
wenn man über jahre mit einem geheimnis
lebt macht das einsam oder mach das auch
überlegen
nein es hat mich selbst sehr einsam
gemacht also zu meinten das thema
homosexualität im fußball ist ja sowieso
ein immer noch schwieriges thema es geht
nicht immer nur darum unter der dusche
sondern auch gemeinsam musst du musst
schon starker kerl sein du darfst dich
ja nicht umsonst heißt es kommen nicht
zu nahe
eine fußballmannschaft ist eigentlich
eine wie eine familie du zeigst
emotionen so zeigt gefühl wenn es ein
tor gibt und wenn du dann vielleicht aus
schwule dazu gestern heißt es kommt mir
nicht zu nahe und dann habe ich
vielleicht in meiner jugendzeit auch bei
diesen sprüchen mitgemacht hayta
schwuler pass oder und aber eigentlich
hat nicht dasselbe pferd verletzt und du
gehst dann nach dem training nach hause
du kannst mit niemandem darüber reden
und du fühlst dich immer mehr einsame
zurückgezogen und ja wenn du dann dich
autos und mit den leuten darüber reden
kannst du nichts einfach so ein gefühl
der freiheit und das macht wirklich hat
mich dann auch viel viel glücklicher
gemacht also heute mit mit meinem
partner
irgendwo jetzt eben warten wir an einem
konzert das war wunderschön
auf der anderen seite waren wir jetzt
gerade in den ferien in sansibar und da
war es wieder wie ein doppelleben also
da durften wir eigentlich nicht zeigen
dass wir schon sind und also den griff
bekommen haben haben sie schon zwei
männer in einem haus also das geht ja
gar nicht und ja wir mussten da halt
einfach wirklich auch sage ich mal
aufpassen und nicht ein fenster halten
heute in der öffentlichkeit da kann auch
diese erinnerung was wahrscheinlich
wieder hoch ja da kann man diese
erinnerungen hoch die ihm du fühlst dich
beobachtet du machst etwas falsches dass
ich nicht richtig was du machst also das
ist dann wirklich wieder hervorgekramt
und jetzt mit dem coming-out wie waren
die reaktionen vor zwei jahren oder
heute noch es war sehr sehr schön also
es ist ja für viele leute ist das thema
homosexualität immer noch etwas fremdes
es gibt vorurteile ein schwuler geht ins
ballett oder eben eine schule kann nicht
fußball spielen und und wenn die leute
dann merken
das erlebe ich jetzt auch mit meinem
partner wenn wir eine eine bauer führen
zusammen eine kleine vereinbart die
leute schauen uns ein bisschen
vorsichtig reihen dann kommen sie rein
dann stellen sie vielleicht einmal eine
frage
am anfang war es lustig haben sie
gefragt ist das auch eine bar für
normale leute und soja oder oder einmal
hat jemand gesagt darf man sagen dass es
hier ein bisschen worden ist
und dann ja das war absolute und heute
heute lache ich über solche sachen und
ich finde es auch schön wenn man offen
und und mit den leuten darüber sprechen
kann wenn sie merken die sind die sind
ganz normal dann stellen sie fragen und
das war wirklich das ist schön und so
soll es ja eigentlich auch sein
sie haben gesagt wir die weinbar also
sie sind nicht mehr arbeiten nicht mehr
als schiedsrichter jetzt haben den
rücktritt bekanntgegeben in diesem jahr
hat das etwas mit dem komiker zu tun
nein aber gar nicht was ich hab wirklich
für mich den moment gesucht wo ich
aufhören kann wenn ich zufrieden wenn
wir nicht noch freude habe und ich habe
einfach gemerkt dass ich sonst sehr
viele spannende sachen nebenbei noch
machen kann
also ich darf aus als lehrer eine kraft
zu führen mit meinem partner reine
vereinbart und auch politisch darf ich
als gemeinderat das ressort kultur und
da habe ich auch den leuten gezeigt
schauen wir können zusammen ein fest
feiern wir können es schön haben egal
wie jemand ist und irgendwann habe ich
dann gemerkt dass wir ein bisschen zu
viel und dann habe ich mich entschieden
auch wenn sie jetzt mal ein bisschen weh
tut weil wir keine schöne zeit war mit
der schiedsrichterei aufzuhören ist für
sie eine tabu freie gesellschaft wohl
niemand ein doppelleben leben muss ist
das für sie überhaupt vorstellbar und
und wenn ja ist das wünschenswert ist
das ein ziel also im bereich jetzt
homosexualität finde ich es wahnsinnig
wichtig dass man frei sein kann und dass
man einfach die leute so respektiert und
toleriert und akzeptiert wie sie sind
und das finde ich dass man da die tabus
aufheben sollte das finde ich dort in
diesem bereich und für den kann ich
versprechen sehr wichtig und man merkt
aber trotzdem es sind immer eben viele
leute noch nicht eigentlich so offen
oder auch in der schweiz gibt es noch
viele punkte an denen wir arbeiten
müssen und geben den leuten zeigen
es sollte doch ein miteinander sein und
nicht im gegeneinander
was hat für sie das geheimnis für
einstellen wird für sie persönlich
also ich habe immer noch meine
geheimnisse und ich finde das auch etwas
schönes wenn man seine geheimnisse habt
sie dürfen einfach niemandem wehtun und
niemanden verletzen finde ich man muss
sich sozusagen freiwillig für sich
behalten und ich war man gezwungen wird
dagegen der gesellschaft gehen
er lacht na vielen herzlichen dank für
dieses gespräch danke gemacht
wir haben echte größe sehr herzlich
jetzt bei mir auf dem sofa svenja
flaßpöhler sie ist treviso finn und
chefredakteurin des philosophie magazins
in berlin und philipp tingler auch er
philosoph und schriftsteller und
literaturkritiker ganz herzlich
willkommen
sie haben vor einiger zeit ein buch
geschrieben über das verzeihen um dieses
buch beginnt überraschend zu erzählen
darin unter anderem die geschichte ihrer
mutter nämlich wie sie ein doppelleben
eigentlich geführt hat und sie und ihre
familie verlassen hat dass sie 14 jahre
alt waren
wie war das für sie das doppelleben
ihrer mutter somit zu kriegen
naja ich finde da steckt ja erstmal die
frage drin was ist denn eigentlich ein
doppelleben oder wo fängt es an also
fängt es schon an bei einer affäre die
man hat die vielleicht auch ein bisschen
ernsthafter ist oder muss da noch
irgendetwas dazu kommen also braucht man
wirklich zwei ganz parallele existenzen
von denen vielleicht sogar die eine
plötzlich viel wichtiger wird als die
die man eigentlich für das leben
gehalten hat und bei meiner mutter war
das nie in dieser weise eine parallele
existenz sondern sie hatte affären und
daraus erwuchs dann irgendwann auch eine
nächste ehe wenn man so will hat meine
mutter eher ein chronologisch
hintereinander angeordnet das
doppelleben geführt in dem sinne dass
sie erst die eine familie hatte und dann
einen schnitt gemacht hat und dann ein
zweites neues leben mit einer neuen
familie angefangen hat und was hat das
mit mir gemacht oder wie habe ich das
erlebt also ich im nachhinein kann ich
meine mutter in ganz vielerlei hinsicht
auch verstehen also wir sind haben in
einem dorf gelebt überhaupt ist
natürlich die sexuelle freiheit für
frauen selbst heute noch etwas ganz
anderes als für männer würde ich sagen
also noch erlaubt die sozialen zwängen
ist richtig mein erlaubt glaube ich
männern in vielerlei hinsicht mehr als
als frauen und gleichzeitig gibt es aber
auch natürlich dinge die ich nicht
verstehen kann im nachhinein und wenn
ich es ganz kurz sagen sollte würde ich
schon so formulieren dass ich unter
dieser komplexität die ein doppelleben
mit sich bringt und auch die verletzung
die an opel leben mit sich bringt schon
auch gelitten habe dass er mitbekommen
habe und ich eigentlich wenn man so will
daraus für mich den schluss gezogen habe
es anders zu versuchen ohne mich selbst
zu kasteien und das ist ganz wichtig mir
geht es nicht um selbstkasteiung und mir
geht es auch nicht um eine moralisierung
aber
ja ich habe das schon die dunkle seite
sozusagen wer sehr deutlich auch
mitbekommen und die dunkle seite hat ja
auch zu tun mit der perspektive derer
die in ihrem vertrauen verletzt worden
sind darüber sprechen wir später in
dieser sendung aber was ich schon mal
festhalten kann und wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe sie sind selber nicht sozusagen
auf den geschmack gekommen selber meine
eltern leben zu führen er nicht so
früher nicht so herzinger sie ja
irgendwie schon respektive sagen sie ist
ledig unter s weh als ich bin ja jetzt
kommt die these dass sie sagen er hat
man eigentlich führen wir alle ein
doppelleben insofern wir manieren haben
heißt das sie werden eigentlich ein ganz
anderer sie würde jetzt gerne hier ihre
schuhe ausziehen und die füße auf den
tisch legen oder wie muss ich das
verstanden vielleicht nicht unbedingt
aber wenn sie damit meinen dass ich
möglicherweise sogar noch lauter und
ruppiger bin als einige leute ohnehin
schon finden dann dann stimmt das
womöglich aber ich möchte gerne anfügen
ich glaube das stimmt auch für sie frau
blanche und das stimmt auch für frau
flaßpöhler also wenn man wenn man
einfach davon ausgeht dass moral wir
haben ja viele schon jetzt über moral
gesprochen dass moral die gesetze und
verbote der gesellschaft sind und wenn
man mal versucht doppelleben ohne moral
zu definieren dann würde ich einfach
sagen ein doppelleben sind zwei
identitäten und zwei identitäten haben
wir alle nämlich die private identität
und die öffentliche identität oder ganz
schlicht ausgedrückt man benimmt sich zu
hause anders als draußen
und das ist übrigens nicht nur das
fundament von manieren sondern das ist
das fundament von zivilisation das ist
das fundament auch des
gesellschaftlichen diskurses und der
demokratie
sie haben ja gerade nen roman
geschrieben gratuliert zum essen bleibt
herr zingler und darin gibt es eine
figur die conny und die conny macht das
ja gar nicht von kondenswasser ich
wollte gerade fragen ob sie konnten
ich liebe connie wie sie sich vielleicht
denken können conny es laut und conny
sagt den leuten ins gesicht was man
eigentlich nicht macht und dann passiert
das was in gesellschaft passiert es
werden dynamiken in gang gesetzt und
leute werden auf sich selbst
zurückgeworfen in dieser konfrontation
das hat ja auch immer was
qatar tisches diese störung auch etwas
reinigendes ja wenn man gegen manieren
verstößt und ich bin sehr dafür dass man
wenn man die regeln kennt sie auch
bricht aber das problem scheint mir da
anzufangen wo menschen diese dieses ziel
historische doppelleben nicht mehr
einzuhalten gewillt sind in dem sie ihre
privaten standards nach draußen tragen
also die trennung zwischen privater
identität und öffentlicher identität
findet nicht mehr statt
und das passiert wenn ich heutzutage
verstärkt weil ihr es oft zu tun haben
mit einer etwas überspannten vorstellung
von authentizität dass ich die dann
dafür sorgt das recht eigene nachsagen
und jetzt sind manieren zum beispiel in
ihrem kern ja eigentlich das gegenteil
von echtheit also wenn sie mehr
versehentlich auf den fuß treten und
sich dafür entschuldigen dann sage ich
ihnen keine ursache das macht gar nichts
obwohl das nicht stimmt ich bin total in
ein authentisches tut wahnsinnig weh
das ist sozusagen ihre idee dass die
daten die alle kennen diese manieren wir
wissen uns zu benehmen das ist alles so
vielleicht eine sehr will ich mal sagen
entspannte form von doppelleben wir alle
haben mehrere ist insofern die rollen
spielen zb nun haben wir ja aber vorher
gerade ein doppelleben gehört was ganz
eine ganz andere dimension hat wohl
jemand wirklich einen großteil seiner
identität nämlich die sexuelle
orientierung verstecken muss und da
würde mich interessieren wie definieren
wir doppelleben aber auch daran machen
die das eigentlich fest man könnte ja
sagen jede gesellschaft hat sie ihre
schamgrenzen jede gesellschaft definiert
was gehört so zum normalen was man leben
darf und was stellen wir sozusagen
jenseits dieser grenze hin
also ich fand jetzt noch mal interessant
tatsächlich zu sehen wie unterschiedlich
doppelleben oder der zwang ein
doppelleben zu führen oder die lust an
doppelleben zu führen
letzten endes ist und ich glaube diese
unterschiede die müsste man tatsächlich
herausarbeiten ich glaube dass der
geschilderte fall wenn ich tatsächlich
gesellschaftliche sanktionen befürchten
muss ausschlüsse
befürchten muss aus bestimmten
zusammenhängen das ist noch mal was
anderes als ich führe ein doppelleben
weil ich es nicht schaffe mein partner
ins gesicht zu sagen dass ich hier nicht
mehr liebe weil ich nicht den mut habe
möglicherweise er eben der wahrheit ins
auge zu blicken und dann eben durchaus
auch authentisch mir gegenüber oder
ehrlich mir gegenüber zu sein insofern
würde ich auch sagen die ehrlichkeit
gegenüber mir selber ist schon ein hoher
wert auch und dieses also das
doppelleben finde ich hat letztlich
schon eine verbindung auch zu lebenslüge
ja also mein mann will das alte nicht so
richtig loslassen man will aber auch
etwas anderes
das finde ich jetzt noch mal ganz
anderes phänomen als erstes das da
geschildert wo das für das ist mir ein
bisschen zu abwertend ich finde wir
sollten diesen begriff des doppellebens
wirklich neutraler fassen als mehrere
identitäten und das trifft dazu auf alle
möglichen konstellationen
sie haben es völlig richtig gesagt dass
es gibt ganz viele konstellationen aber
diese abwertende beigeschmack ich finde
nur weil vorhergesagt worden ist ganz
allgemein ist es erstrebenswert eine
gesellschaft ohne doppelleben das heißt
ohne tabus zu haben da können wir uns ja
mal fragen hat uns donald trump
gesellschaftlich weiter gebracht weil
dieser mensch jeden tag eigentlich in
seinem leben dinge praktiziert für die
politiker früher ein leben braucht und
wenn dieser über griffigkeit und auch in
der verquickung zum beispiel von politik
und geschäft hat uns das weiter gebracht
ist braucht es nicht auch tabus es
natürlich auch auf wenige sehr scheu
satz verstimmte grenzen wo es dann
einfach nicht weiter geht ohne dass die
gesellschaft schaden nimmt und jetzt
wäre ja eine these ist braucht diese
tabus weil sonst menschen sich einfach
so ungehobelt benehmen dass das
zusammenleben noch nicht mehr
funktioniert eine andere idee könnte ja
sein es braucht diese tabus oder wir
wollen diese tabus weil wir ja auch
dieses geheimnisvolle anziehend finden
also unser foto gast hatte ja gesagt
geheimnisse zu haben ist auch etwas
schönes und mir fiel auch noch georg
simmel ein der mal gesagt hat
geheimnisse sind individualisierungs
momente
das sind die momente wo wir uns ganz
gehören da sind wir uns ganz nah und
niemand kann uns rein
ist es wahnsinnig interessant und das
stimmt alles man kann sagen dass
menschen mit einer gewissen ich stärke
ihre identität entwickeln
auch in dem was sie kontrollieren was
andere über sie wissen oder nicht das
gehört zu einer reifen persönlichkeit
ist ein bestimmtes wären hat die man
vielleicht auch nicht halt oder nicht
mit jedem tag
ich finde aber diese das was hier
weniger die transkription und den
lustgewinn den mann aus der trans aus
der norm überschreibt umziehen kann
und jetzt werde ich sollten wir uns mal
fragen wie entwickelt sich das
eigentlich also sie haben es vorhin
angesprochen bestimmte sachen sind scham
behaftet und zum beispiel heutzutage ist
vielfach der falschen körper mit scham
behaftet
die befassung mit dem körperlichen es
virulent und der falschen körper ist der
körper die in meine bezugsgruppe
sozusagen nicht für den richtigen hält
ich sehe ich definiere das gar nicht
anders jetzt aber dass es mit scham
behaftet
und wenn sie zum beispiel jetzt nicht
menschen die sozusagen sollen sich sagen
würden sich im falschen körper genauer
sollen gemerkt diese möchten sie sind
für ihre referenzgruppe zu dick oder zu
klein oder zu hässlich oder und wenn sie
jetzt ein leben führen indem sie ihren
körper als projekt betrachten
meinetwegen auch als
optimierungsprojekte und das auch noch
öffentlich teilen zum beispiel über
soziale medien
dann wird vielleicht der regelmäßige
verzehr eines bürgers zu einem
doppelleben
da müssen wir fragen welche qualität hat
diese transaktion das wollte ich nur
sagen also dass man einfach sich mal die
frage gestellt wie ist es dann um die
gesellschaft bestellt wenn sowas
plötzlich zur transaktion wird also dir
der begriff der transgression oder der
überschreitung der ist glaube ich hier
wirklich ganz zentral weil wenn man zum
beispiel einen philosophen wie michel
foucault nimmt der war ganz viel drüber
nachgedacht hat oder georges partei dann
ist das interessante an der figur der
überschreitung ja dass das gesetz oder
die grenze nicht etwas unterdrückt was
vorher schon da war ja eigentlich würden
wir gerne aber wir dürfen ja leider
nicht sondern das gesetz bringt das
begehren hervor
die grenze bringt das begehren hervor
gerade weil es verboten ist willig ist
und das kennt wahrscheinlich jeder der
hier sitzt ja dass man irgend genau das
will was man eigentlich nicht haben darf
das also wir haben seit neuestem einen
hund selbst unser hund hat dieses
prinzip schon verstanden dass er lieber
das nimmt was auf dem tisch liegt wo
klar ist dass darf endlich haben als das
was leben ins körbchen legen
das ist glaube ich ihr so tief nicht nur
in uns menschen drin sondern auch schon
in tieren drin genau also dass das dass
diese figur glaube ich ganz wichtig ist
für diese sehnsucht nach dem anderen und
natürlich immer auch die projektion ja
diese diese projektion das andere wird
mir die erfüllung geben
das was ich habe dieses erste leben das
eigentliche das ist unerfüllt das
eigentliche ist immer woanders
und das macht einen ja auch verrückt
wenn man wenn man sich dem absolut
verschreibt vielleicht um diese runde
auch zu beschließen für das erste würde
mich auch interessieren hertinger hatte
jetzt einen sehr weiten begriff vom
doppelleben insofern dass eigentlich
jeder ein doppelleben führt weil wir uns
zu benehmen wissen zumindest manche sie
hatten er einen engeren begriffs wenn
sie sich jetzt mal auf ein team das
begriff einlassen darauf haben sie haben
doch auch im doppel den islam doch in
dem ich denke in dem sinne haben wir
natürlich alle ein doppelleben in dem
sinne dass wir wenn wir öffentliche
wesen sind die sich die sich jetzt wie
hier zum beispiel bewegen
natürlich tragen wir da in gewisser
weise wenn man so will masken ja also
wir wir müssen uns anders geben als als
zu hause auf dem sofa ich sitze ganz
anders da ich bin anders gekleidet ich
habe überhaupt was an und so weiter so
und natürlich ist das soja und in dem
sinne ist natürlich diese frage wer sind
wir eigentlich wer sind wir wirklich
eine sehr schwierige und auch
philosophisch überhaupt nicht geklärte
frage die hängt ja immer zusammen auch
mit der frage nach dem doppelleben gibt
es so was sich das eigentliche ich
versprechen nachher gleich weiter und
vertiefen diese fragen auch noch wir
diskutieren zuerst noch einmal weiter
oder schaue noch in eine andere richtung
und zwar zu menschen die leidenschaften
haben für die sich irgendwie schere oder
von denen sie denken die dürften nicht
sein die dürften sie sich leben und sie
leben sie im verborgenen ja bei mir
sitzen jetzt victoria sie arbeitet aus
domina und daneben sitzt einer ihrer
kunden der möchte sie nicht erkannt
werden deswegen trägt er diese maske und
wir werden auch seine stimme verfremden
vielleicht die frage gerade an sie
warum möchten sie nicht erkannt werden
genau es sind im ganzen
deutschsprachigen raum als außenhandel
ist wieder unterwegs und das können uns
auf sie das machen wir verkaufen das mit
backend und wer weiß dass man ihnen weiß
dass überhaupt jemand dass sie zu
viktoria gehen also im engsten
freundeskreis werden 12 vermuten
ansonsten niemand und was ist ihr
geheimnis was lebens sie bei viktoria
aus ich habe meine wangen atrix wirklich
ausleben
das heißt es von oben bis unten nicht
nur die massen wie jetzt und auch in
high heels umlaufen beim sex ist ein
sehr tolles material und vielleicht auch
das musik oder durch und durch den
lieferanten kann und das schloss ganz
angenehm ist wie lange leben sie dieses
doppelleben schauen naja du hast du
schon 20 oft machen sie das hier auf
gendefekte her
also ja sein weil im monatsdurchschnitt
viel unterwegs und mittlerweile der
beratungs und sehr gutes verhältnis und
dort kann ist so rumlaufen wie schlecht
das ist auch zum frühstück schon ein
ziehen also im studio und tod des
bisherigen und sogar dass er das schon
ganz angenehm vermuten sie was werden
ihre berufskollegen die familie freunde
von ihnen denken wenn sie das wüssten
das problem dass man kann das nicht
erklären
wenn wir wollten etwas so die ist oder
dass er das frisch ist wenn man zu viel
erzählt das mit um das zu beschreiben
oder gleich zu erfüllen was das schöne
daran ist dann schützen die gleich
verdacht und was auch sein kann ist dass
es vielleicht keine freund oder dass
eine ferne welt gilt leicht versteht
also die da wieder ausgegrenzt werden
welt nicht verstehen könne auch andere
schützen indem sie das nicht
weitererzählen ja was mich auch
interessieren würde
sie klingen nicht so als ob sie sich
schämen würden für diese besondere
vorliebe was haben sie für ihr
verhältnis zu dieser vorliebe ist das
eine selbstverständlichkeit geworden
nach diesen 30 jahren oder nehmen sie
das manchmal wissen mit tumoren schaden
sich selbst von ausnahmen denken was
macht er jetzt da ist also ich mag mich
näher in die wattenscheider ein halber
und sagen so kann ich das umsetzen kann
stehe und dass markus schon persönlich
das ist ganz normal und es wäre
natürlich auch schön aber dass im freien
oder im normalen leben kosten könnte und
das geht nur in großstädten also und
dann als wahrscheinlich auch noch einen
bestimmten straßen also wie viele
vielleicht durch die landstraße auch
immer weiter so mit paris oder new york
das ist jetzt schon gar kein gemeint und
da schüttelt sie noch einen kurzen lauf
zwei streit als ist mein ergebnis
victoria sie tragen keine masken
warum nicht bei mir meine ganze familie
und freundeskreis wissen was ich mache
also ich gehe sehr offen mit diesem
thema oben und auch mit meinem beruf
aber noch nicht so lange eine zeit lang
haben auch sie ein doppelleben geführt
oder führen ist es dass das rechtlich
genau also die ersten monate wo ich
diesen job angefangen habe habe ich
meiner familie nicht erzählt was ich
mache das habe ich dann erst
ein paar monate später wo ich mich dann
entschieden habe auch eigenes studio zu
eröffnen das war vor etwa fünf jahren
oder wo sie angefangen haben
ich war dass mit diesem geheimnis zu
leben dieses doppelleben zu führen
geheimen dann zu diesem studio zu gehen
und so ich fand das anstrengend und
belastend für mich es ist schwierig es
ist vor allem man fühlt sich nicht so
ganz authentisch ist so war es bei mir
ja also für mich war das eher
erleichtern das ganze oder mich zu augen
meiner familie gerade so die nächsten
personen also den wo ich wirklich lieb
habe das zu sagen auch wenn die aktion
nicht ich bin ich eher nicht so ganz
positive aber sie haben eine
zwölfjährige tochter darf ich sagen die
war damals neuen sie hat das alles
locker genug also bei ihr war es
tatsächlich toll ich denke das lag daran
dass sie noch keine vorurteile hatte als
ich sie konnte zwar mit dieser mit
allgemeinen mit thema sex was anfangen
schon mit neun jahren war das einfach
schon in der schule irgendwo präsent war
und wo ich ihr das erklärt habe fand sie
das eigentlich so nur jeder macht seinen
job fand das nicht schlimm
wobei sie das realisiert hat dass das
jetzt das nicht unbedingt kommunizieren
möchte in der schule ich meine viele
ihre kunden und ihre kolleginnen in
diesen domina studio leben ja ein
doppelleben wir leben diese menschen mit
dem geheimnis für viele ist das
belastend das was ihnen hilft ist
tatsächlich dieses geheimnis zu teilen
oder also ich stelle mir das viel
schwieriger vor wenn eine person da gar
nicht drüber sprechen kann
ich sehe das sehr auch bei den kunden
gerade die dann kommen die dann oftmals
auch darüber sprechen wollen also das
ist nicht nur dieses erleben von einer
session sondern auch dieses sprechender
vorsprechen danach hast du diesen da
auch sehr offen und erzählen sehr gerne
drüber wir sind an ihre kunden von a bis
z also das kann man gar nicht so sagen
dieses dieses denken dass nur irgendwie
unternehmer das sind ist nicht wichtig
also ich hab wirklich jeder berufsgruppe
bei mir im studio schon gehabt
die seien interessant und also es gibt
auch nicht es gibt diese person wo man
sagen würde
von dem würde man das zu allerletzt
denken dass gibt es aber auch dieses
große auseinanderklaffen zwischen dem
was die beiden machen in dem was die
sonst machen das ist so das ist so und
das ist ja das was gut für mich ist das
schon mittlerweile einen allen alltag
also mich wundert das nicht mehr aber
ich denke die gesellschaft durchaus also
da gibt es ich glaube so dieser
berufsgruppen die irgendwo religiös
irgendwo im beruf sind oder eben ärzte
die dann wirklich sehr ausgefallene
sachen praktizieren das sind so so
themen wo ich denke auch die könnten das
gar nicht nach außen kommuniziert wurde
es würde den den leben komplett nass
dietringen wirklich in die tabuzone
holen machen diese verbotene dinge auch
weiß ich wahrscheinlich verboten sind
das ist ein teil des reizes nämlich an
vielleicht müssen sie war so kurz
erläutern was sie so alles anbieten
damit wir eine ungefähre vorstellung
haben was da passieren ihren ja gut also
die liste ist ja wirklich ewig lang das
kann man sich was ich fange an
also wir fangen natürlich mit den ganz
normalen sachen die jetzt glaube ich
jeder so ein bisschen kennt auch aus dem
fernsehen erziehung rohrstock erziehung
irgendwelche schläger spieler mit
strohmatten reduktion fetische zum
beispiel bis hin zu ns spielern kaviar
spielern klinik spielen wo tatsächlich
sekunde auch irgendwo mit dem skalpell
an diese behandelt wird und so weiter
und so fort
wir sehen hier auch noch bilder damit
wir einen groben eindruck haben wieso
ihre studios aussehen es gibt dann einen
tagen einen weiteren die dann auch
unterschiedlich aussehen jetzt
eigentlich hier diesen tag room wo
ziehen sie denn für sich persönlich die
grenze nur sagen sie das mache ich nicht
da wohl der kunde das wünscht
das ist wenn da wenn ich merke das geht
in richtung schwere körperverletzung
oder wenn ich nicht nur sicher bin
sondern auch schon das gefühl haben es
könnte eine schwere körperverletzung
sein
das ist das ist ganz klar außerdem wenn
ich das gefühl habe dass es pathologisch
wird oder also wo das nicht mehr
für mich als vorliebe gilt sondern
wirklich irgendwo als eine störung weil
das konnte ja natürlich
form von einer entwicklung in die
falsche richtung laufen und sich
entwickeln
wie ist das bei ihnen liegt bei ihnen
den verbotenen ein besonderer reiz der
sache oder ist das eher so dass das
inneres bedürfnis ist dass die haus
leben ja das ist boden akzeptiert sie
haben gesagt sie können das nicht
weitererzählen ja doch so seine weiter
südlich und das etwas andere wäre dann
eine behandlung im studio und für mich
ist das ungewisse
das scheinen also wenn man weiß was
passiert und dann mit solchen leuten
dass sich janis spielen dass zähne nur
dann als eigentlichen trikots spielen
können die auch mal wie weit man gehen
kann mit ein also das schmerzte trifft
und solche sachen
das ist halt das ist es nun aber das
muss ein vertrauter sein und man hat uns
selber neuer grenzen
man weiß vorher nicht was passiert wie
freistaat angeschnallt oder angebettelt
und sie dort doch schon ein bisschen vor
spannung und das hat ein lehrer heinz
also dieses ungewisse dieses
ausgeliefertsein dieses ohnmächtig sein
ich habe das wie ein spiel aber das
gleichzeitigen teil ihrer identität
das haben wir so sagen ja also ich liebe
person machen sich einen gefangenen und
dann führen sie sich total frei kann man
das so sagen kann ach ist das rein
person
im moment ist noch in einem ganz anderen
film beim einen scheiß was passiert und
wenn das nach alles vorbei ist so
erleichterung dann ist das dann auch
fühlen sie sich von victoria auf eine
art verstanden wie sonst niemand sie
versteht
das tool ja wäre unsere gesellschaft
oder unsere welt eine bessere wenn es
solche praktiken nicht mehr tabu wenn
man geht das einfach so ausleben könnte
wenn das nicht mehr charme besitzt wäre
ja und nein also ich sehe die positive
seite von dem ganzen aber auch eben die
negative ich denke für viele wird das
total erleichtert so wie das auch bei
mir war wo ich das äußert habe also dass
jemand tatsächlich bin
so zum beispiel wie dieser kunde oder
der wirklich eine neigung hat oder
vorliebe hat die jetzt nicht gefährlich
ist aber wir haben natürlich auch ganz
andere sachen beziehungsweise menschen
haben verschiedene vorlieben und
präferenzen wo wenn das nicht tabu wer
das vielleicht nicht so gut wäre für die
betroffenen unter fliegen die sich das
ansehen der 44 beider seiten also das
ist ja ich sehe ich sehe da wirklich vor
und nachteile von dem ganzen ja erstmal
vielen herzlichen dank für das gespräch
in beiden
ja manche menschen leben in ihrem
doppelleben vorlieben aus die von der
gesellschaft nicht akzeptiert sind
andere menschen aber gehen weiter und
machen in ihrem doppelleben verbotene
dinge und bächen das gesetz der fußball
hooligan gewalt und exzess zum zweiten
zum geheimen leben werden und sicher zum
größten teil aus sozialer wird ein
romantik bis friedrich der ganz normale
durchschnittsbürger wir ruhig und glaube
ich vor dem fernseher
märz sportmediziner altersrente nach für
sie das rennteam vorgesetzte sich oder
der mann aber die ehrenbürgerschaft
aussehen als räuber und poli gespielt
und gespielt das hat wirklich empoli mit
der polizei mit gegnerischen fans ja
bevor es knallt durch einspritzen
schießen gleichzeitig und das faultier
deilmann vos knall fall dass abdi ab
bundes dieses glücksgefühl anna sorokin
die russisch-deutsche hochstaplerin
wollte den gehobenen new yorker
lebensstil nicht bloß auf perfekten
bildern konsumieren
sie wollte teil dieser welt sein und gab
sich als tochter eines russischen
oligarchen und als künftige
millionenerbin aus im frühling 2009 10
wurde sie wegen betrugs einreichen
geschäfts bekannten und mehreren hotels
angeklagt und schuldig gesprochen
urteil mindestens vier jahre haft
jahrzehntelang fälschte wolfgang
beltracchi kunstwerke im stil großer
meister und verdiente millionen bei
fälschen ging beltracchi hoch
professionell vor seine bilder benutzte
er sogar alten ausgerechnet sein
teuerstes bild wurde ihm zum verhängnis
diese fälschung gemalt im stil von
heinrich campendonk wurde für 2,8
millionen franken verkauft eine
laboruntersuchung zeigte beltracchi
benutzte eine farbe die es 1914 im
angeblichen entstehungsjahr des gemäldes
gar nicht gegeben hatte dass ich gerade
bei dem bild eben nicht selbst gemacht
weiß genommen habe sondern irgendein er
eine frau leitner
urteil sechs jahre haft ja und ich
begrüße jetzt ganz herzlich bei uns
reinhard haller auf dem sofa es theater
und gerichtsgutachter und auch
spezialist für suchterkrankungen herr
haller wir haben jetzt unterschiedliche
formen von doppelleben schon
kennengelernt
es gibt solche die sind einfach im
verborgenen statt andere werden zur
richtigen straftaten
was ist mit denjenigen die straftäter
werden kommen die einfach nicht mehr
raus aus ihrer lügengeschichten oder
gehört das zum planen schon dazu dass
man wirklich das gesetz auch brechen
will
ich glaube wir müssen generell
unterscheiden zwischen einem doppelleben
dass man will und eines zudem
angetrieben wird es gibt natürlich auch
das krankhafte doppelleben gefährdet
bei der multiplen persönlichkeit haben
können und es gibt das kriminelle
doppelleben meines erachtens spielen
hier dann zwei momente eine rolle zum
einen dass man halt einfach eine tat
begeht die sanktioniert wird man will
nicht erwischt werden und dies dann
gezwungen ein doppelleben zu führen
einerseits der unauffällige bürger
andererseits der schreckliche verbrecher
zum zweiten glaube ich dass er für eine
große verbrecher häufig auch getrieben
werden
durch diesen wunsch überlegen zu sein 90
tendenzen machtansprüche zu haben und
die ausleben zu können also
beispielsweise bei serien attentätern
diese half mit polizei so ein spiel
betreiben
das ist natürlich auch ein triumph
gefühl wenn brände passieren und alle
schreien wo ist der feuerteufel wecken
dass sein sind günstig und so weiter und
ich bin im besitz des wissens und alle
haben von mir angst und ich sitze am
frühstück ganz unauffällig am tisch
nebenan aber es nimmt natürlich manchmal
auch dramatische reformen an weil am
schluss steht meistens ein absturz
und vielleicht ein weibliches delikt zu
nehmen sie wissen der die männer sind
immer die besseren verhältnis 10 zu 1
also darum jetzt ein weibliches delikt
kleptomanie also dass frauen die sehr
oft auch sehr guten verhältnissen kommen
im übrigen oft auch sehr hübsch sind
sehr wohlhabend um das stillen zivilen
stellen gehen und hat eine doppelte
identität der führen auf der einen seite
hätten es ist gar nicht notwendig auf
der anderen machen
etwas buntes werden dann erwischt man
gibt ihnen am anfang eine bedingte
geldstrafe dann eine höhere bedingte
geldstrafe dann irgendwann einmal eine
bedingte haftstrafe
und irgendwann einmal ist es soweit sie
werden verurteilt sondern zweijährigen
haftstrafe dergleichen und ich habe
einen fall sogar gehabt da war das so
diese frau wenn sie dann in haft gehen
musste war der richter als das ist
herangewachsen und das überhaupt also
das leben dann ausgeflogen leben über
viele jahrzehnte ist dann auf diese
dramatische art und weise aufgeflogen
sie sind ja auch einer der psychiater
die immer mal wieder mit josef fritzl
gesprochen haben sie kennen den mann
persönlich den österreichischen
verbrecher der 24 jahre lang seine
tochter in einem kellerverlies unterhalb
seines hauses gefangen gehalten hatte
auch sieben kinder mit der tochter
gezeugt und das erschütternde an diesem
fall ist ja nicht nur dass ein mensch
dazu fähig ist sondern dass die ehefrau
von josef fritzl im nachhinein gesagt
hat sie hat die ganzen 24 jahre lang
nichts mitgekriegt wie kann es sein dass
ein doppelleben so ein extremes
doppelleben nicht auffliegt wir diese
fall ist tatsächlich deren der
kriminalgeschichte in dem das
doppelleben denke ich mir in seiner
reinsten form unter dem seine grenzen
wenn man so will auf jeden fall gelebt
wird nämlich das mitten unter uns das
ist ja nicht irgendwo im fernen hochdahl
oder wie jetzt in holland auf einem
abgeschiedenen hof passiert sondern
mitten in einer stadt ein mensch ein
solches leben führt und ich kann mir nur
vorstellen dass er um sich eine aura
verbreitet hat dass man ihn nicht
nachfragt also sehr autoritär und man
traut sich nicht zu fragen was machst du
dir stunden lang da unten
natürlich hat es da manchmal auch
situationen gegeben werde mir erzählt
hat die höchst peinlich waren weiß ich
was hat der pampers dabei gehabt mehrere
packungen auf den supermarkt seine frau
kommt die trinken sorgt dass marken wie
pampers und in wirklichkeit hat er
mehrere kinder also dort damit zu
versorgen und als solche dinge hat es
gegeben aber dieses gefühl macht ausüben
zu wollen in einer ganz extremen art und
weise und der blüten welt draußen zu
zeigen was sie alles nicht
wissen ich hingegen bin im besitz des
wissens das ist glaube ich das was
diesen fall so einzigartig ausmache
neben seiner unglaublichen dimensionen
sieben kinder 24 jahre haben sie frühen
ja schon gesagt es geht auch um nazismus
sie haben auch ein buch geschrieben die
nazis muss falle narzissmus ist ein
großer sein forschungsgebiet auch von
ihnen kann man sagen dieser narzissmus
da steckt ja alle ein stück weit in uns
drin haben wir also alle auch ein
bisschen den hang zum doppelleben oder
kommt zu so einem richtig großen
doppelleben noch was ganz anderes dazu
irgendein anderes charakter merkmal der
narzissmus ist derzeit natürlich ein
beliebtes thema ich glaube auch dass wir
tatsächlich im zeitalter des narzissmus
leben seit der jahrtausendwende
unnatürlich ist der reform sozusagen das
inneren doppellebens das heißt die
meisten sind die innerlich schwache
menschen komplex haufen und brauchen
nach außen in eine wunderbare fassade
die immer gelobt die man bewundert wird
und ähnliches aber es ist natürlich auch
extrem krank war ich muss jetzt alle dem
gesetz verbieten
bei den folgenden ausführungen nicht an
amerikanischen präsidenten zu denken
weil man dafür keine ferndiagnosen
stellen aber tatsächlich sind netz ist
natürlich perfekte doppelleben menschen
in dem sieben nach außen etwas ganz
anderes repräsentieren als nach innen
darstellen
und im übrigen dass münchen wird auch
alle auch gefährdet in dieser art und
weise ein doppelleben führen zu wollen
das führt bei uns in unseren bisschen in
eine andere idee noch rein die ihnen
sehr wichtig ist nämlich die sogenannte
status schauen also diese angst an
sozialem status zu verlieren eine idee
die ulrich greiner so bis in die welt
gesetzt hat die vorstellung das ist
unglaublich peinlich ist wenn man den
sozialen status nicht mehr hart geht man
eigentlich erreichen wollte also ich
möchte jetzt viele sachen sagen dass ich
gar nicht weiß wo ich anfangen soll
ich möchte ganz kurz nur bemerken dass
nicht immer auf den armen
warum hacken sollten es wird auch sehr
interessante kreative menschen so
bezeichnet worden und zwar zu recht
thomas mann zum beispiel und thomas man
es auch deswegen ein interessantes
beispiel weil er nämlich die alternative
strategie gewählt hat er hat
bezüglich seiner homosexuellen begehren
auch ein doppelleben verzichtet und die
sublimierung gewählt und das äußert sich
dann in kunstproduktion das nur kurz
vorweg
und dann möchte ich kurz zuvor schon als
schüler sagen einfach weil das auch
rosstat aufgenommen hat es ist ein
interessanter gedanke dass das verbot
die lust seiner übertretung inspiriert
der natürlich nicht immer richtig ist
zum beispiel in der im fall von herrn
erlacher das verbot der homosexualität
inspiriert nicht das begehren das zu
übertreten durch indem man homosexuelle
sich orientiert also wir müssen schon
immer gucken über was für eine art von
doppelleben sprechen wir auch wenn wir
über transgression reden das ist mir
sehr wichtig weil in diesem in dieser
art von doppelleben wo es mit einer
repressiven gesellschaft zu tun hat ich
spreche jetzt nicht von so fritzl fällen
sondern einfach von menschen aufgrund
von eigenschaften wirklich
diskriminierungen und herabwürdigung
erfahren liegt in diesem doppelleben
meines erachtens interessiert mich was
sie dazu sagen aber meines erachtens
auch ein emanzipatorischer aspekt weil
dieses dieses gezwungen seien an der
grenze der norm zu leben herne hat es
sehr schön erzählt das schärft das
bewusstsein für die eigene dauernde
herabwürdigung und das äußert sich
möglicherweise in einem
emanzipatorischen impetus ja dass das
stimmt sicher also aber wenn man die die
these die foucault michelle der
französische philosoph da in die welt
gesetzt hat wirklich ernst nimmt und sie
durch denkt dann passt es eben doch weil
er sich gerade er war ja selber
homosexuell sich gerade mit sogenannten
perversionen was man so perversionen
damals noch genannt hat beschäftigt hat
und er hat gesagt dass es überhaupt die
perversion als das andere gibt es
natürlich ein effekt der grenze und des
verbots und der der norm setzung das ist
normal und das ist krank also insofern
gibt es da natürlich schon einen einen
zusammenhang dass das was wir da so als
grenze setzen dass andere überhaupt erst
hervorbringen
also so ist das erste bier und aber was
was ich noch richtig was ich aber noch
in jedem fall wo ich sie unterstützen
wollen würde und
wo auch glaube ich dass das
emanzipatorische moment liegt wird das
sicher stark machen wollen ist
tatsächlich zu sagen wir sollten uns
eben wenn wir jetzt noch mal diesen fall
neben uns eben nicht in das geheimnis
flüchten und es heimlich machen sondern
dass gerade die tatsache dass man dazu
steht dass man es sagt dass man sagt ich
mache das hat eben einen
emanzipatorischen rückkopplungseffekt
auf die gesellschaft letzten endes war
man natürlich damit genau diese grenze
auch problematisiert herr haller muss
unglaublich schmunzeln müssen sie glaube
ich war kurz alleine ich glaube es
schwebt so diese frage ein bisschen im
raum also wann beginnt das doppelleben
zum problem zu werden und ich glaube da
müssen wir schlicht und einfach ein
leidens begriff nehmen wenn jemand
darunter leitet die betroffene person
selbst weil ihr der stress zu groß wird
weil seit ein oder mehrere leben führen
muss dann denke ich mir das ist ein
problem wenn jemand das ganze verdrängt
also sozusagen sich in einer
neurotischen mechanismus möchtet oder
wenn die umgebung der vertrauensverlust
oder dergleichen zu leiden beginnt das
ist im übrigen auch wenn man es mal so
es geht heute nicht um den normalen
narzissmus dem begrüßen wir alle dass
die gesellschaft den stadtweit viele
schon demokratisch geworden österreich
funktionieren benutzt ich glaube nicht
das ist ein hilfreicher begriff ist sind
wir jetzt auf alles mögliche
ich denke mir der laizismus ist als dann
ein problem wenn jemand zu leiden
beginnt darunter ich halte das ist
selbst weil es einsam wird um ihn oder
die die bevölkerung oder die umgebung so
zu sagen weil es eben unter dem
neunzigsten und das eine nennt wertungen
und so weiter nicht zurecht kommen aber
ich wollte etwas anderes sagen aber
bevor sie etwas anderes sagen müssen wir
diesen punkt noch machen wir unangenehme
führen
wir waren aber der punkt ist doch dass
ist doch irgendwie auch ein bisschen
schwierig weil die frage wo jemand zu
leiden beginnt die seinerseits
individuell aber nasa die jetzt schon
gehört haben immer auch gesellschaftlich
bedingt ja ich glaube man kann das nicht
so richtig von einer zeit wenn nicht
ganz gut was dazu sagen darf es ist ja
sehr schwer diese sehr verschiedenen
phänomene da überhaupt struktur momente
auszumachen weil die fälle so
verschieden sind
aber ich glaube was vielleicht doch
einen moment ist und was sie beide jetzt
auch angesprochen haben ist doch das
problem und da fängt das glaube ich an
eben problematisch zu werden wie
integriert man anteile des selbst wie
integriert man begehren in das eigene
leben die irgendwie nicht so richtig
passen also die in automatisch werden
dahingehend dass sie das leben das man
eigentlich für radikale infragestellung
sie ihr gerät man die und da gibt es
noch verschiedene lösungen die sie jetzt
auch angesprochen haben wir schon bei
entweder ein gelebtes jahr main lebt ist
hausmann sublimiert ist also was freud
mir der mann zitiert was freud mit der
veredelung des triebs meinte dass mein
sublimation genau da müssen wir noch ein
satz dazu sagen sublimation also die
idee dass zb kunst daraus wird man nimmt
diese energie und macht etwas neues
schönes das aber natürlich die frage
stellen wie sieht es eigentlich um die
qualität von kunst zum beispiel
literatur aus wenn es in der
gesellschaft nichts mehr zu sublimieren
gibt haben wir verschiedene
möglichkeiten also man macht kunst
daraus platt gesagt man gewöhnt sich
manieren an was haben wir noch die
möglichkeiten hier gehen zum psychiater
ja also ich glaube dass das doppelleben
durchaus auch eine psychologische
funktion hat und jede von uns wieder
daran wesen das unterstelle ich einmal
sucht immer wieder dieses doppelleben
ich sage ihnen ein einfaches beispiel
wenn der mensch verrückt wird auf
irgendeine art und weise als entrückt
und dann verrückt bleibt das ist doch
ein urbedürfnis dass wir alle haben wenn
man uns berauschen beispielsweise wenn
wir da eine seite ausleben
die wir sonst eben nicht haben ich
keinen menschen verdienen war ich mir
nicht ganz sicher ob sie reden können
und dann komme ich am freitagabend ins
gasthaus zu halten das ganz gast aus
freyend unterhalten ist auf eine
kürzliche art und weise oder menschen
diese gestresst sind
die ruhig werden unter drogeneinfluss
oder neben größen ideen bekommen
es ist zumindest zeitlich limitiert das
für wenige stunden
oder ich sage ein anderes beispiel wurde
das doppelleben sehr wichtig ist
pathologie der berufswahl
sie wissen ja dass menschen die im
prinzip also an ihre psychischen seiten
ein bluterguss ohren sind die können
also zum mörder werden aber sie können
auch zum zahnarzt zum schlachter zum
chirurg werden
dann haben sie das ganze ich bin meinen
eigenen beruf nicht ausnehmen sie
wechsele leute die selbst verrückt sind
aber irgendwann ja wahrscheinlich
ich glaube den begriffen dass das eine
große rolle spielt in unserem leben dass
wir über kurz oder lang also zu sagen
auch diese insel haben wo wir ein
doppelleben führen können für eine
bestimmte zeit ob man es dann ein ganzes
leben durchführen kann das weil ich hier
zu sitzen aber ich glaube ein begriff
der doch auch ganz wichtig ist der
begriff der fantasie oder also die
fantasie ich meine was mir die ganze
zeit durch den kopf geht wo fängt das
doppelleben anfängt es eigentlich schon
da an wenn ich mir beim sex jemand
anderen vorstelle
ja manisch immer den gleichen ist das
schon ein doppelleben verrate ich das
schon meinen partner möchten sie jetzt
ja ja ja nein ich finde das super dass
sie das dass sie den aspekt der fantasie
ansprechen weil das bringt uns zu einem
riesen komplex von doppelleben die wir
noch gar nicht erwähnt haben nämlich
diese doppel digitalen doppel existenzen
die wir zum beispiel auf engsten raum
finden das ist ja quasi die umsetzung
einer einer zweiten wirklichkeit auch
mit fantasie aber auch so dass es
sozusagen allen bewusst ist dass das
nicht tatsächlich eine widerspiegelung
der leben und profile ist die die zu den
jeweiligen fotos ich finde wir müssen
unbedingt darüber reden dass es auch
erklären genau was sie meinen
ich habe mir im vorfeld ja auch gesagt
dass sie den gedanken interessant finden
des soziologen armina see der von menu
denken gesprochen hat also diese
vorstellung hier posten etwas auf
instagram oder entwerfen eine neue figur
auf instagram unser alter ego unser
doppelleben ich und ein zweites menü ist
immer darunter
man weiß also immer schon auch einmal
das an guckt das war eigentlich eine
andere person eine normalere eine
weniger geschönte dahinter stehen und
das interessante ist und da komme ich
zurück zum begriff der stadt osch aber
ich habe nicht vergessen dass sie mich
das vor 40 minuten gefragt haben wie man
das eigentlich hier integrieren kann
das obwohl alle wissen dass das
manipulierte bilder sind haben diese
bilder trotzdem leitbildfunktion
und jetzt ist doch die frage wieso ist
das der fall und für mich ist das der
fall weil sich hier auf instagram ich
finde instagram wahnsinnig faszinierend
in dieser hinsicht zwei pole zeigen die
sich auch in jedem doppelleben zeigen
nämlich einmal der pool der
ästhetisierung der transgression wenn
sie so wollen und dann der anspruch der
wahrhaftigkeit und diese beiden pole
werden übrigens als ausbrüche an jedes
foto gestellt wo sie in die
wahrhaftigkeit darf ins tor es sind ja
immer noch fotos auch wenn sie zeigt
eine zeichnung keine animation und an
die fotografie auch ein auf instagram
immer noch befindet sich in diesem
spannungsfeld von verschönerung und
wahrhaftigkeit und instagram klappt hier
eine eine neue ebene auf die quasi
zwischen den polen des doppellebens
gespannt ist und wir haben hier ein ein
riesenprojekt von von verdoppelung der
welt eigentlich es ist ungeheuer
faszinierend wie sehen sie das lässt
sich ihr habt hat die digitalisierung
befördert die ich ideen vom doppelleben
das macht das mit den menschen
unzweifelhaft ist es eine hervorragende
möglichkeit denken wir nur daran was im
internet alles so geschieht wo also
menschen ihren hass ausleben können also
ganz andere seite ich habe auch schon
ein paar gerichtlich untersuchen müssen
und das waren als erschreckend normale
menschen verdienen wenn man das nicht
zugetraut hätte der beiden sich diese
seite auch drinnen haben dass sie unter
starken statistischen entwerten den
tendenzen sozusagen leiden ich denke mir
das wissen wir lieber das geschieht auf
diese art und weise als sie rennen
jemand anderem auf deutsch gesagt ein
messer in den bauch als wenn die
aggressivität sozusagen digitalisiert
wird das glaube ich ist etwas positiv
ist und insofern ist die digitalisierung
sozusagen das kriminellen die
virtualisierung der kriminalität ist
bezüglich durchaus etwas positives aber
was ich hier dazu sagen wollte das ist
also mir gefällt das nicht so gut wie
nie
und zwar aus einem ganz einfachen
bildern können wir ja letztlich nicht
die emotionalität hinein
legen dann das entscheidende für die
persönlichkeit eines menschen für seine
ausstrahlung stephen hawking sagt der
für das überleben der menschheit ist das
emotionale das empathische das
sympathisch das nicht rein liga das
können wir können natürlich schon
tausende von smileys und so weiter
entwickeln aber es wird trotzdem niemals
diesen tiefgang erreichen
denn die richtige emotionalität hat und
stephen hawking ist ein kalter physiker
war wenn ich so sagen darf attestieren
er hat in seinen letzten reden immer
wieder gesagt das überleben der
menschheit wird nicht nur davon abhängen
ob werden fällt darum besiedeln sondern
ob wir die emotionalität treten
das ist nämlich das was letztlich das
spezifisch menschliche sein wird ist im
übrigen auch dass bei dem es im prinzip
kein doppelleben gibt aber das ist dann
extrem interessanter punkt und genau auf
den wollte ich auch noch raus wenn wir
gerade social media anschauen dann sind
doch oft gerade die momente des komplett
authentischen oder zumindest dessen was
uns glauben macht jemand sei komplett
authentisch die wir angehen und
faszinieren also jemand der in tränen
ausbricht sportler die in tränen
ausbrechen oder politiker und politiker
die einen lachanfall haben und nicht
mehr können vor lachen
diese videos gehen wir aber warum weil
die menschen irgendwie komplett echt
sind
also ist es nicht die antithese dazu
dass es im netz vor allem um doppel
neben fleisch ich glaube sie machen hier
das was was leider häufig passiert
nämlich sie bewegen sich in ihrem milieu
sie dürfen nicht vergessen dass andere
bilder also dass das leute wie kendall
jenner millionen followers haben da geht
es nicht um tränen ausbrechen sondern da
geht es um die inszenierung von körpern
da geht es um die inszenierung von
lebensstils und produkte da geht es eben
auch um status charme wenn ich bestimmte
produkte oder bestimmte körper
eigenschaften nicht habe also dieses
spektakulären sachen die sind wie eine
kurze insel der erleichterung aber die
riesen accounts mit den riesigen anzahl
von oberster sind accounts die in ein
lebensentwurf präsentieren
ich würde gerne um diese sofa runde auch
wieder zu beschließen zeigt das letzte
frage noch in den raum stellen für den
moment
was wäre wenn die welt maximal tolerant
wäre das eine frage die vorhin auch an
der bar diskutiert worden ist gebe es
dann gar keine doppelleben mehr oder
weniger
ich finde sie werde er sie wäre dann
sterbenslangweilig teile nämlich diese
meinung dass einer guten partnerschaft
dazu gehört dass die jeweiligen teile
kein doppelleben haben sondern ich
glaube es müssen sich beide auch hier
die insel aufbewahren nur dann bleibt es
spannend
das prinzip des lebens ist immer näher
also sprich vertrautheit und autonomie
nähe vertrautheit das ist bei datum so
beim herzschlag bei der sexualität bei
allen diesen dingen und das doppelleben
das leben sozusagen die andere seite und
ein stück weit braucht man das endlich
leben mit daten zauns und dich hin genau
also partnerschaften in denen der
jeweilige teil überhaupt kein zweites
leben hat nämlich etwas sehr privates
die sind tot
ganz kurz noch sie beide also ich glaube
nicht dass das die lösung ist das dass
wir in einer maximal toleranten welt
kein doppelleben bräuchten weil ich
glaube die verletzung die entsteht in
nicht bei allen ja es gibt ja auch paare
die führen eine offene beziehung und
haben sich irgendwie so darauf geeinigt
dass das möglich ist es gibt ja auch die
polizei ja also menschen die mehrere
menschen gleichzeitig lieben und das
auch irgendwie in wechselseitigem
einverständnis funktioniert aber es gibt
eben doch das gros der der paare
funktioniert eben anders da empfinden
wir tatsächlich den seitensprung als
verletzung und da für mich kommt noch
mal so ein interessanter aspekt rein
dass wir eben wenn jemand mit jemand
anderem schläft dann empfinden wir das
als tiefe kränkung aber was ist denn
eigentlich wenn ich eine tiefe geistige
beziehung zu jemandem habe die ja auch
erotisch sein kann auf ihre weise
das ist für uns viel unproblematischer
ja so damit will ich nur sagen man kann
ja auch formen finden um mit anderen
ganz tiefe beziehungen zu haben
die vielleicht den anderen nicht
verletzen und man kann sie trotzdem
haben also das interessiert mich diese
anderen formen nur ganz kurz ich möchte
nur noch mal das augenmerk richten
darauf dass wir schauen sollten auf die
qualität von transaktionen und zb fragen
und stellen wie
ist eine gesellschaft wirklich
freiheitlicher wenn sie flugreisen
tabuisiert anstelle von seitensprüngen
danke für diese frage schon platz nehmen
im publikum genau
vielen herzlichen dank ja uns fürs erste
machen wir hierbei sofa runde wieder
eine pause und ich übergebe sehr gerne
das wort den spoken word künstler pedro
lenz der uns sagt dass ein doppelleben
zu tun hat mit stricken braucht nicht
unbedingt mathematik studiert jetzt
schaute das zwar aber mäßig aus
drum hsg neckartal aber mit einer doppel
abendliche zieht verlage aus ohne das
doppel mit doppel aber labs zwischen 20
und 50 jordan range zwischen 20 und 80
60 yorker erlaube die beste aus auch
wenn der 30 jahre lang ist obwohl aber
geführte starbucks kilo in der vom
jahrgang 150 aber das macht er mit der
neil schlagergeschäft kriegen die
ratgeberliteratur organ 80 69 50 uhr
sorgt der widerruf beim top of base
doppeltop europa press ihres doppel
engagement aus zum beispiel sein zu
glauben man muß die wenige zeit mehr für
die jetzige verarbeiter mir noch
gedanken zur um mehr im kopf heute
doppelt night der beste sagt schmid
schule machen und alle liebhaber von
banales wie es heute aber für brawn ist
obwohl aber für dich der spruch
verbessert glaubt obwohl aber wird
einfach gleich fünffach ende beste für
halb aus doppelt aber nicht wenig von
der analyten ist obwohl dafür
verwechselst neue vermutlich mit dem
namen und meine kleine tochter kleid das
sie einfach gestrickt und folglich - auf
eine dreifach geschickt wo sie ist
für evt druck in lohr mit fasse zusammen
ist obwohl habe stocker kleid aber nicht
einfach gestrickt dass man jetzt
kompliziert turner aber überhaupt nicht
immer behaupten dass platz doppel habe
sie gebissen kompliziert
ja bei mir sitzt jetzt jemand derart dem
doppelleben andere menschen ein geschäft
gemacht hat stefan heyken leitet seit 20
jahren eine so genannte alibi agentur
und nennt sich selbst freiraum manager
genau was muss ich mir doch dieser
wusste ja vor 20 jahren war das ja
überhaupt nicht als eine geschäftsidee
gegründet sondern das war so eine
sonneborn and idee damals war der
begriff alibi agentur halt hätte er
nicht mehr spontan ausgedacht hat aber
freiraum manager freiraum management das
ist eigentlich viel mehr das was wir
machen mit denen wir zu tun haben aber
wir schaffen leuten alibis das in
augenschein natürlich können sie auch
ein paar beispiele machen natürlich
viele von den sachen die heute genannt
wurden sind zum beispiel wie der der
homosexuelle dem wir ein doppelleben dem
ihr eine freundin zur seite stellen
das freundin sie sogar mit nach hause
kommen die sich bei den eltern mit
vorstellt die mit zu geschäftsessen usw
bsc spielt darin die sie bezahlten genau
richtig bis hin zu einzelnen abenden wo
wir ein doppelleben über einen ganz
kurzen zeitraum organisieren wir haben
auch diese ganzen sachen die heute
angesprungen sind das betrifft eher so
unsere gesellschaft die wir hier in
deutschland haben wir haben aber auch
viele kunden die kommen halt aus ganz
anderen kulturen die haben ganz andere
fälle die wir uns gar nicht vorstellen
dass man dafür überhaupt ein doppelleben
benötigt deren personen die zum beispiel
in asien aus asien kommen chinese er
sagt ich arbeite hier beim deutschen
immobilien autokonzern am fließband und
ich verdiene super geld haben gutes
leben jetzt kommen nach vielen jahren
mal meine eltern zu besuchen und wollen
sehen was ich mache am fließband zu
arbeiten ist das unterste für deren die
gesellschaft dort das wenn meine eltern
das mitkriegen oder sehen würden dafür
bist du nach deutschland gekommen um
hier am fließband zu stehen
dann würde er sein gesicht verlieren das
ist was was wir überhaupt nicht
verstehen können zum guten job zu haben
sicheres einkommen und gut bezahlt ist
für uns top soda organisieren wir für
ihn eine firma ein kleines unternehmen
wo er mit seinen eltern hin kam und er
sagt ich brauche ein schreibtisch steht
auch ein computer und ich brauche dann
steht dahinter
dann ist alles super und das müssen
meine eltern einmal sehen
so solche sachen sind ganz banale
geschichten haben ja das ist ja wirklich
dann dokumente emails und so
marschierten namensschildern da kommt
die der wird begrüßt in der firma als
wäre der top kollege als wäre der
abteilungsleiter natürlich und das ist
egal was sie da tun
lügen ist nicht illegal es kommt darauf
an was man damit macht wenn man sich
dann natürlich da einen beruflichen
vorteil ergaunert oder irgendetwas
illegales macht klar dass unterstützen
er nicht und hört bereits auf ab ja ich
bin geblitzt worden
ich habe genug punkte ich brauche
jemanden der gesagt hat dass er fährt
das machen wir nicht okay oder den
letzten fall der ich persönlich
abgelehnt habe war einer sagte meiner
freundin schwanger geworden bitte ruft
sie an und sagt dass sie bzw
das ist auf gar keinen fall also das war
natürlich ist da muss man sehr schöne
rose haben also solche sachen sehen war
aber zum beispiel eine krankheit hat das
für sich behalten möchte der
arbeitslosigkeit natürlich ein burnout
hier im vorhinein schweizer mal ganz
viel in zürich auch ganz viel mit
burnout patienten zu tun
die sagen so leben wir ja gar nicht
schämen die sagen wenn ich jetzt in die
klinik gehen und die haben mich total
lassen auch nicht kommen zurück dann
fängt die ganze sache wieder von vorne
an
dann denken die mitarbeiter hier der ist
doch nicht mehr doch ein bisschen
matschiner berne dem stimmt doch was
nicht mehr den kümmert mich ernst nehmen
er hat dann das gefühl nicht mehr
akzeptiert zu werden als der große chef
als der oder der geschäftsführer oder
als der abteilungsleiter er sagte ich
jetzt paar monate ausfallen dann brauche
ich weiß was ich in der firma sagen kann
dass ich für die firma im ausland
unterwegs beenden sonst bringt mir die
ganze chur nichts und krebskranke hiv
patienten haben wir sehr viel was ist so
der klassiker einer meiner ersten fälle
waren krebskranke ein älterer mann der
sagte er ich habe den größten fehler
gemacht zu sagen dass ich krebs habe
leute geben ja nicht mal mehr die hand
geschäftsleute machen keine geschäfte
mehr mit mir die sagen der ist doch
sowieso im halben jahr weg was soll ich
mit dem noch was unterschreiben
und wenn ich meine schüler kriege ich
ins krankenhaus muss oder irgendwas habe
dann möchte irgendwas anderes ab jetzt
ein ende
ja und das organisieren sich verschaffen
nach alibis wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel
fremdgehen möchte natürlich weg bin zu
einer konferenz sondern wir natürlich
jetzt genauso aus das ist so aber
prozentual gar nicht mal so viel habe
ich am anfang vermutet
ich denke wenn die warnanruf die hat gar
nicht gedacht dass ich mal anruft und
wenn jemand anruft damit gesagt
vielleicht männer und dann geht es um
affären oder gelegt war ewig hat ewig
gedauert bis muss also interessant war
es ist in swientek tektur für tabu zonen
in der gesellschaft aus astra wüste
kommen die leute zu reden und wollen das
in verdecken geheim
ja ja ja wir haben viele dominas wie so
was haben sie über den menschen gelernt
in den nächsten 20 jahren
die gesellschaft war ja eh und je so
also das hat mich insofern geprägt dass
ich glaube ich sehr direkt bin und sehr
offen und mit dass man mir die wahrheit
so ins gesicht knallen kann und ich
nicht böse reagiere oder sachen
persönlich nehme und management ich zu
meinen wurzeln kommt dann bis nächstes
jahr nicht mehr eingeladen und so ich
höre ja am telefon dass solche sachen
gibt kann man so reagieren was mehr
toleranz für ehrlichkeit ihm gegenüber
haben sie definitiv also klar und
schlechtes gewissen
warum sie haben lügen und nach rügen
aber wenn man die ganzen sachen bekommen
mitbekommt und manchmal stundenlange
gespräche am telefon und kunden hat am
telefon die weinende kein wort mehr
heraus kriegen die wieder auflegen
ein vergewaltigungsopfer sind dabei und
auch der der eine affäre hat da sind
viele dabei die frau anruft und sagt
mein mann ist seit ein paar jahren
querschnittsgelähmt durch ein autounfall
da geht halt nichts mehr und ich habe
von ihnen das einverständnis seit vielen
jahren wenn du mal jemand finde es lebe
ist aus ich kann nicht mit meinem
eigenen gewissen damit leben dass du auf
sex verzichtet aber es gibt sicher auch
die anderen fälle wo jemand einfach den
seitensprung möchte zum beispiel ihre
partnerinnen oder so und das finden sie
wahrscheinlich auch nicht gut oder
in dem fall jedoch die goldene regel
anwenden nein ich mache es mir nicht an
dass über andere zu urteilen wie ich
mein leben für das für ich halt so wie
ich es mag und so wie ich das nach
meinen ethischen vorstellungen für gut
halte aber ich mache mir nicht anders
anderen zu diktieren oder zu sagen was
sie zu tun oder zu lassen haben welchen
stellenwert sorgen wahrheit und
ehrlichkeit haben in unserer
gesellschaft ja ja schon sehr hohen auch
eine beziehung vor allem aber es geht
halt nicht immer man kann sich nicht
immer auf man kann entweder im feld
gegen polizisten hier sind ja nicht
minister nicht nur im fußball so dass es
sind auch viele andere bereiche wo man
berufliche nachteile zu erwarten hat
wenn man sich ja wenn man sich als
homosexuell ausbaut und es geht halt
nicht und sie haben vorhin gehört ein
leben ohne doppelleben ist langweilig
wenn sie auch sagen dass die prise salz
im leben dieser seite also das
doppelleben schon oft sehr interessant
ist auch der interessantere part für
denjenigen der es führt und wenn wir
hier ja oft gehört ist es belastend und
das sagen uns die kommen ja auch am
anfang das was der grund ist sie auch
bei uns melden
wir nehmen einen großen teil dieser last
ab diese organisation ein doppelleben
selber zu organisieren ist extrem
aufwändig man muss an so viele sachen
denken und das im kopfbereich man muss
sich allerdings mache ich manchmal mit
kunden zusammen sitze und die ihre
tagebücher fotoalben krankenakten mehr
alles ausbreiten und sagen wie sie das
in letzter zeit organisiert haben ist
sie von unserer agentur gehört haben das
ist schon immer aber haben sie nennen
sich einen modernen freiheitskämpfer das
ist müssen die übertrieben oder der
freiheitskämpfer also frei rom manager
würde ich da er nicht dazu sagen ja weil
ich schon ja schon die freiräume von
vielen leuten halt irgendwie verstärken
ja genau dadurch dass sie diese dinge
ermöglicht dass man das geheim machen
kann verstärken sie diese
gesellschaftlichen erwartungen dieses
korsett das hilft mir überhaupt nichts
mit emanzipation
da kann man salziges geheimnis und erst
ein bis sich die gesellschaft endet
bevor man diese sachen aber sie helfen
nicht dabei dass sich die gesellschaft
verändert
ich helfe den leuten dabei nicht
krank zu werden nicht ja sie diese
belastung zu haben schlaflose nächte
tabletten zu nehmen weil sie ihr
doppelleben irgendwie nicht offenbar
haben sie die dienste schon mal für sich
selbst benutzt ich finde einzige der es
nicht kann ich musste mich ja dann mal
mitarbeitern
wir haben übrigens über 1000
schauspieler die dafür sorgen wir haben
sehr viele echte partner für die das mit
unterstützen
und ich sage mal niemanden ein wein so
viele geschichten wo der beste freund
die beste freundin irgendwas
ausgeplaudert hat sie haben auch gesagt
ehemalige kunden helfen ihnen jetzt
genau wie viele dieser angemeldeten sind
die nicht erpressbar weil sie dinge über
die wissen dann würde die agentur hier
nichts 3 20 jahren bestehen also da
würde ich mir ins eigene fleisch
schneiden erhalten erstmal vielen
herzlichen dank für das kurze gespräch
sie gehen es doch überall so sein oder
werden noch weiter diskutieren
zusätzlichen daran
ja fast überzeugt sie herrn eigenes
geschäftsmodell also ökonomisch ist
wahrscheinlich überzeugend ethisch
ethisch bin ich mir nicht sicher also so
weder für die die ein doppelleben führen
wollen noch für die die getäuscht werden
also fangen wir mal mit denen an die
getäuscht werden also wenn ich jemand
eine systematische und das machen sie
also täuschen menschen systematisch dann
halte ich sie eigentlich in der
unmündigkeit weil ich ihnen die
möglichkeit nicht gäbe auf der auf dem
hintergrund von einem bestimmten wissen
eine entscheidung zu treffen also ich
weiß du gehst fremd also kann ich mir
jetzt überlegen verlasse ich dich oder
nicht diese möglichkeit ist mir genommen
und und dadurch würde ich sagen halten
sie die menschen in unfreiheit und sie
berauben sie der möglichkeit von
selbstbestimmung das ist das eine und
das andere das klang jetzt schon an
das betrifft er sozusagen die diesen
doppelleben führen also nehmen wir den
krebskranken den burnout kranken oder
wen auch immer
ich glaube in so was sie machen ist
systemstabilisierend sie stabilisieren
ein system was eigentlich nicht okay ist
es ist nicht okay dass leute die so viel
arbeiten dass sie davon krank werden das
noch nicht mehr öffentlich sagen dürfen
oder in ihrer firma sagen dürfen das ist
nicht okay dass jemand der krebskrank
ist das nicht öffentlich sagen kann weil
er da beruflich berufliche nachteile hat
das ist alles wirklich nicht okay und
deshalb würde ich sagen die eigentliche
ermächtigung oder die eigentliche
freiheitskampf bestünde ja darin diese
menschen zu ermutigen und sie zu
unterstützen ihr leiden sozusagen in die
öffentlichkeit zu tragen so einfach
gesagt aber mit so viel
unterschiedlichen fällen zu tun hat weil
ich telefon höre ja mensch mein partner
der ist alkoholiker der hat jeden morgen
pünktlich um acht uhr seinen stuhlgang
brachte aber erst um 9 uhr auf
ich liebe ihn ich kann mich nicht
trennen aber ich führe ein doppelleben
eine andere beziehung in der ich mich
glücklich fühle in der ich die kraft und
energie sammeln um einen kranken partner
ja um dort halt mit ihm zusammenzuleben
und ich habe natürlich ganz andere und
chris geschichten auch dabei wo ich sage
das kann ich absolut nachvollziehen aber
gut aber sie machen ja sie unterstützen
ja auch menschen wo sie es nicht
nachvollziehen können also weil sie
sagen ja das ist deren sache das
interessiert mich nicht sie interessiert
ja gar nicht ob nur wenige zu recht oder
zu unrecht das würde ich sagen das ist
schon problematisch oder für mich ich
tue mir damit schwer weil ich die grenze
wo das doppelleben beginnt interessantes
sie ich glaube doppelleben ist dann
gegeben wenn man nach außen hin eine
rolle spielt und es gibt einen zweiten
teil denn nur ich weiß also nicht jemand
anderer auch keine agentur
das ist glaube ich der entscheidende
grund das mit das doppelleben wirklich
etwas wert ist dass es mein ganz eigenes
ist vor dem niemanden der auch nur den
geringsten interessant also sie nehmen
jetzt eine definition wo sie sagen
würden naja ereignis gleich freiraum
manager aber es kann manager von
doppelleben
aber damit haben sie sich jetzt ein
bisschen elegant aus der affäre gezogen
ich wollte eigentlich wissen was sie
über das geschäftsmodell denken
ja das denke ich mir das spricht für
seinen geschäfts verstand sozusagen also
vielleicht ist er auch im doppel dem
nicht weiß ist ich dachte schon ans
theater kennt ja die zürcher der leute
sie könnten sich bewerben werden weil
sie nicht aber es hat mir was mir jetzt
nicht von bord zu richtigen weiß sagen
wieso das ist das eben menschen wenn sie
eine psychische krankheit haben oft
gezwungen sind nach außen in etwas
anders darzustellen und eine andere
rolle zu spielen das ist zum beispiel
für die politiker über die wir so gerne
schimpfen aber das ist wirklich bei
denen ein großes elend oft wenn es ein
psychisches problem haben dann trauen
sie sich nicht hilfe zu suchen sei es
depression oder ähnliches burnout
allerdings muss ich sagen das ist ein
ausdruck den ich wollte es ein flitzer
mehr verwendet wird insofern sehr
schätze weil er dem zur enttabuisierung
geführt hat psychische probleme also
spricht
es sagt jemand tut sich sehr schwer zu
sagen ich leide unter depressionen ich
kenne da also beispielsweise einen
großen firmen chef der leidet unter
schweren depressionen und immer wenn sie
hat am meisten los ist in seinem
geschäft ereilt in die depression und
dann heißt es ich muss auf einen
wichtigen kongress auf einen
erholungsurlaub alte geht dadurch seine
firma voll stolz und zeigt jedem der es
hören will
ich habe es burn-out sozusagen wenn eine
tapferkeitsmedaille aus dem letzten
krieg wird das präsentiert und das denke
ich mir ist auch etwas positives weil
man dadurch sozusagen mit einem
englischen ausdruck der psychischen
enttabuisierung rechnung getragen hat
wobei jetzt gerade das geschäftsmodell
von einem jahr dem widersprechen würde
dann sagt er hat viele kunden die ein
burnout haben das nicht wenn der tross
vor sich her tragen sondern im gegenteil
so sehr darunter leiden dass es nicht
öffentlich als lösegeld so läuft viel
arbeitslosen aber ich wollte sagen dass
dieses beispiel beendet das meines
erachtens ist nicht das beste ist dass
er zu bieten hat aber ich glaube dass
das was er macht also durchaus auch sind
die wichtigkeit hat aber mit echtem
doppelleben nicht so viel zu tun
vielleicht also jetzt mal jenseits von
von definitions fragen würde ich gerne
noch die frage in den raum stellen von
welcher welt träumen wir eigentlich das
ist immer so eine große frage die
bisweilen auch schon angeklungen aber
frau voßkühler ist ganz eindeutig ja
glaube ich der meinung wir sollten dafür
sorgen dass menschen sich nicht schämen
müssen die in burnout haben die sollten
dafür sorgen dass menschen die krank
sind dazu stehen können und in ihrer
verletzlichkeit angenommen werden dass
es schlussendlich vielleicht die
humanität auch die menschlichkeit einer
gesellschaft
jetzt könnte man ihnen den vorwurf
machen dienen sie nicht jeden wieder zu
diese humanität wieder zu untergraben
weil sie die menschen ermuntern bei
ihnen ein alibi zu kaufen habe ich den
homosexuellen habe der sagt ich lebe in
einem homosexuellen feindlichen umfeld
um mein eigener vater der würde sehr
aggressiv der sowieso alkoholiker oder
hab irgendwie ein drogenproblem wie ich
nicht dort auto und ich bin noch student
ich wohnen zu hause
man kann jetzt nicht sagen der muss der
muss sich outen und der andere die
eltern ammann recht auf die wahrheit und
dann können die eltern entscheiden was
immer
das maße ich mir nicht an er kann das
ruhig dahin geheim halten
er sagt er will sich erst wenn er
ausgezogen ist wenn also eine eigene
wohnung hat ist doch völlig in ordnung
nicht jeder hat auch das anrecht auf die
wahrheit und die domina jetzt aufs land
ziehen unser vorstand in berlin
das war kein problem die nachbarn wissen
was ich mache aber ich habe zwei kinder
und jetzt wollen wir auf dem land und
ich befürchte dass die kinder gehänselt
werden gemobbt werden dass wir nicht zum
grillen eingeladen werden bei den
nachbarn wenn die wissen das was ich
beruflich mache meiner seite ist doch
völlig morgen also dann
schützen sie ihre privatsphäre ihre
kinder und ja sie nicht über sagen hier
dass man sich beruflich und ja ich
bediene da die kritische ich glaube aber
das problem bleibt einfach dass das es
gibt bestimmt fälle wo sie wo sie
menschen tatsächlich helfen bestimmte
situationen besser zu leben
trotzdem finde ich aber dass sie sich
als sagen wir mal dritter in eine sehr
komplexe situation einmischen die sie
wahrscheinlich im ganzen gar nicht
überschauen können und genau und da aber
aber eben eine systematische täuschung
kulisse aufbauen womit sie letzten endes
auch ja macht ausüben womit sie menschen
in der in der unwissenheit halten und
das also ich könnte das mit meinem
gewissen nicht vereinbaren einfach weil
man weil man so eingreift in solche
diffizilen komplexen gefüge und
vielleicht genau um die sprechen nachher
gleich weiter über die gefüge ein teil
des gefüges ist ja auch diejenige person
die in ihrem vertrauen getäuscht wird
nämlich das sogenannte opfer einer
solchen beziehung und wir sprechen mit
einer solchen person die unter dem
doppelleben ihrer eltern zu leiden hatte
und die sieht nämlich im moment gerade
bei uns sind publikum ja bei mir sitzt
eine frau die mit 13 jahren erfahren hat
dass sie ein so genanntes kuckuckskind
ist das also ihr biologischer oder
leiblicher vater nicht derselbe ist wie
der von den geschwistern wie war es für
sie damals mit 13
ich haben sie sich gefühlt dass sie das
erfahren haben so richtig alleine also
doch hast du nicht das einzige kind von
diesem einen einzigartig aber zum
anderen auch sehr alleine einsam und
auch irritierend aber es war zugleich
auch ein neuanfang also ein neues selbst
zu finden also die dies zu glauben sie
gar nicht auf einen schlag
wir sehen sie sind jetzt verkleidet hier
mit sonnenbrille verstellter stimme und
da muss ich erst mal fragen was sie
machen das um sich selbst zu schützen um
andere zu schützen das ganze ist immer
noch tabu anschauen besetzt im umfeld
bewusst denn davon ist bevor sie das
erfahren haben ihre geschwister
die geschwister die geschwister wussten
dass das heißt sie wurden absichtlich
getäuscht über mehrere jahre für das zu
einem vertrauensverlust danach dann in
die ins familiäre umfeld nach wie vor
ein verständnis dafür dass ich habe das
ja von ihr meint forschung und deshalb
konnten die wirklich sein das ist denke
ich sagen über überschritten ist
über den jetzt doch gleich mir
vorstellen das ist ein schock wenn man
das erlebten dann ist man wütend zu sein
die leute das nicht gesagt haben aber
sie haben gesagt also das wurde ihm früh
verständlich gemacht der ganze fall
warum das verschwiegen
verschwiegen wird gibt es momente heute
muss ich manchmal denken es wäre
vielleicht besser gewesen deswegen
herzlich ans licht gekommen
ja nein fragen also ich bin froh das ist
das ist draus ist also merkt auch in den
beziehungen zum einen mehr weil es
draußen weil es wahrlich ist die
betroffenen eigentlich auch weiß und zum
anderen haben sie mir gegeben wie ich
damit umgehe ich denke wenn sie das
nicht getan hätten hätten sie mir im
vorhinein weggenommen
die ich damit umzugehen habe und so
konnte ich es selber entscheiden und
habe auch sein umgang damit geschult
oder fielen auch noch sehr vorsichtig
damit um sie kommen jetzt hier
verkleidet danke trotzdem eher für den
mut das sind diese senden gekommen haben
friedlich ins kurzen einblick verdanken
es war von der erleichterung die rede
wenn so etwas ans tageslicht kommt das
gefühl es fällt eine last von mir ab
viele menschen die uneheliche kinder
sind berichten ja auch davon was sie
immer den eindruck haben es stimmt etwas
nicht
herr haller diese erleichterung wenn das
alles rauskommt
kennen sie die auch von ihrer
psychiatrischen praxis gibt es solche
menschen die irgendwann dann merken
jetzt ist es endlich raus auch von
denjenigen die selber ein doppelleben
geführt haben das ist praktisch unser
tägliches brot das wir eben dinge
entdecken die nicht angesprochen sind
die verdrängt sind und es ist ein
grundgesetz der psychologie der
psychoanalyse wenn man die dinge zur
sprache bringen
dann werden sie weniger brisant dann
werden sie weniger krankheit zu erregen
und insofern glaube ich dass es immer
dann wenn ein geheimnis angesprochen
wird fallen gelassen
das geheimnis ist das ist auch
erleichterung bringen kann außer bei
denjenigen die das doppelleben suchen um
nazistische bedürfnisse zu befriedigen
aber sonst ist es in der regel so dass
damit eine stresssituation beendet wird
und letztlich muss man halt immer auch
aufpassen das wollte ich auch singen
sagen
am schluss seines doppellebens steht
durfte enttäuschung das haben sie ja
schon gesagt diese bittere erkenntnis
dass jemand getäuscht worden ist als man
vertraut der partner oder letztlich bei
der enttäuschung auf sich selbst und als
kriminalpsychologen oft enden diese
dinge auch sehr gefährlichen der
katastrophe ich erinnere nur an diesen
fall romo in der schweizer der auch
gespielt unter anderem als ein junger
mann aus wohlhabendem haus der folge
medizin zu studieren doktor zu werden
eine tolle stelle bei der weko in genf
zu haben das hat alles nicht gestimmt
17 jahre lang ist er hat dass eine
familie getäuscht als es dann über seine
geliebte aufgeflogen ist der alle
miteinander umgebracht in österreich
haben wir einen ähnlichen fall gehabt
ein schwerst spielsüchtiger das sind
einer guten fassade verborgen hat das
alles weg war die wohnung und so weiter
wollte er das seiner frau und seinen
kindern nicht zumuten und hat alle
miteinander getötet sechs personen
insgesamt
also wenn das doppelleben zu ende geht
das ist eine derart radikale
demaskierung dass es oft an zur
katastrophe kommen kann also beides ist
möglich es kann eine erleichterung
bedeuten oder es kann sogar das trophy
kommt haben sie fälle jetzt erlebt in
ihrem umfeld wo irgend jemand gesagt hat
ich brauch jetzt kein alibi mehr ich
hab's meiner frau gesagt alles wird ich
bin erleichtert dass es sehr oft nur
eine zeitlich begrenzte dauert manchmal
über jahre manchmal über weniger monate
wenn welche man habe der escort arbeitet
und sagt ich habe mich jetzt tatsächlich
verliebt und das könnten ernsthafte
beziehung werden aber ich muss das erst
noch herausfinden und ich will mich
jetzt die erste zeit noch nicht
offenbaren und gucken ist es wert ist
etwas ernsthaftes da ist das eine ganz
begrenzte dauer wenn ich jemand der sagt
ich habe 14 diagnose krebs bekommen der
vater meiner frau
der ist vor einem jahr an krebs
gestorben meine frau die es damals ein
riesen loch gefallen oder die
selbständig erfasst ihre firma ist
bankrott gegangen wenn ich ihr jetzt
sage ich habe krebs dann das kann ich
nie im leben machen
ich will erst herausfinden ist es was
gutartigen etwas bösartig ist ich will
mich erst behandeln lassen um dann mit
ihr zu sehen
die super positiven fälle wo sie mit
einem alle die etwas überbrücken kann es
auch oft so der fall
aber ich würde sie gerne trotzdem
nochmal faden gibt es nicht auch den
fahrer jemand anruft und sagt ich
brauche es nicht mehr und wo sie
eigentlich denken oh blöd das war jetzt
lief gerade zugute also nach 20 jahren
das ist ja das ist ja gang und gäbe das
haben wir eigentlich jeden monat das
irgendwas auslaufen was neues beginnt
was na klar ich habe dass dir der
längste kunde der seit kommt dann das 17
jahren die aktionäre
ich habe mich gerade so worauf sollen
wir eigentlich hoffen ihm zusammenleben
sollen wir darauf hoffen dass wir
möglichst ehrlich und offen miteinander
umgehen und keine alibis brauchen oder
dass ihr freiraum manager mäßig auch
bezüglich um selbst lernen mit unseren
neigungen so umzugehen dass wir die haut
hinreichend gut kaschieren können was
niemand darunter leidet oder was ist das
idealbild des zusammenlebens sie
belastet also ich würde ich würde sagen
die die große kunst besteht schon darin
dass man versucht diese eben diese an
alle die nicht so richtig passen oder
oder dieses begehren nach dem anderen
das also ich für mich ist diese hat
dieses doppelleben immer etwas von
abspaltungen ich spalte irgendwas ab ich
lebe irgendwo etwas aus was ich was ich
mich nicht traue vielleicht auch mit
meinem partner zu leben oder ich habe
angst ihn zu verletzen oder was auch
immer und die die herausforderung wäre
denke ich schon eben form zu finden dass
das in irgendeiner form zu integrieren
in mein leben wie auch immer in der
fantasie in der sublimation ob das
vollkommen gelingt ja oder ob es dann
doch letzten endes immer diesen rest
gibt denen man sich versagt also ich
habe am anfang diesen begriff der
kasteiung gebracht der mann mann kast
als ich mein erlaubt sich etwas
bestimmtes nicht weil man sein leben
nicht gefährden will was man hat und was
ein letztlich stabilisiert
wahrscheinlich ist dass sogar ja dass es
diesen rest immer geben wird aber ich
glaube solange man davon überzeugt ist
dass das leben was man hat diesen
preisen vielleicht dann doch wert ist so
lange kann man es halten
ich glaube dass du ein stückweit
doppelleben brauchen sonst werde die
ganze geschichte ist eher langweilig wir
könnten keinen krimi mehr anschauen weil
da werden ja auch laut und lauter
doppelleben geführt und wir müssen
vermuten weil dahinter der täter ist ich
denke allerdings auch also was seine
aufgabe ist eine die schon eine enorme
macht bedeutet wissen ist macht und ob
er damit verantwortungsvoll umgehen kann
das kann ich nur hoffen
aber ich will es vielleicht der
kriminologie ist er ist der psychologie
pur
ich will nur sagen dass das doppelleben
für eine große rolle spielt dem leben
und der erwartungshaltung von uns allen
anhand folgen des kleinen beispiels also
nehmen sie alles geschieht in ihrer in
ihrer straßen verbrechen und man sagt
der xy war der mörder der sexualtäter
was geschieht dann
dann sagen die nachbarn zuerst also
furchtbar das hätte ich nie gedacht der
war so nett und so unauffällig und habe
mir die tüte tasche getragen und die tür
geöffnet und so weiter am tag eins am
tag 2 heißt also ich muss sagen bissl
komisch ist mit der schiff mal
vorgekommen das war ganz eigentümliche
typ also schon ein ganz anderes
doppelleben dass wir von ihm annehmen
dann kommt der tag 34 psychocoach 4
[Gelächter]
beckmann waren schauspieler vorneherein
mit begriff bleiben vielleicht noch ihr
schlussphase also für mich ist die lüge
auf eine offene form der höflichkeit hat
gar nichts negatives zu deuten sonst was
für mich total wert neutrales geben auch
ganz banale fälle wenn man es macht ja
meine meine ex-freundin fliegt ihr zum
urlaub und habe mich gefragt auf ihr
haustier aufpasse meine neue will aber
überhaupt nicht dass ich irgendwie was
damit zu tun hat
und die wurde aus rast jetzt brauche ich
jemand der den hund nach hause ecke
vorher immer gefangen nimmt und zu mir
nach hause bringen damit man hier neue
sieht ihr süßer und ist ja gar nicht von
der ex zu ganz banale geschichte haben
ja wo wir denken das gericht ja gar
nicht an unseren kunden das nicht so oft
auch an der ganz anderen person das team
mit der wahrheit nicht umgehen kann oder
die auch gar nicht hören will und da
fragt man sich doch muss denn das banale
leben eigentlich so kompliziert werden
vielleicht schauen ich weiß es nicht ich
danke ihnen ganz herzlich dass sie
diskutiert haben zum thema doppelleben
mit uns herein flaßpöhler haller vielen
herzlichen dank für die wirklichkeit
ja vielen dank auch von meiner seite und
wenn sie jetzt das doppelleben gepackt
hat jetzt gleich der firmen die
unzertrennlichen ein psychodrama von
david crowe und bürger aus dem jahr 88
mit jeremy irons in einer doppelrolle
das schlusswort übergebe ich an
petroflex geht's mir im kopf oder geht
es weiter geht es mit zwei köpfen der
leute haben ja immer ganz genau wo es
jedesmal nummer hobbys und leitner
behaupten
wieso machen ist vor und unternehmer
gleichzeitig besonders bis vor einem
monat gestimmt es wird ein mann ist
gestimmt forscher bis vor einem monat
gestimmt ungefähr bis vor einem monat
bestimmte spuren bis hat einmal gesagt
stimmt das bizarre episode eine manie
sache stimmt nicht ganz
da bist du deine sache stimmt bis vor
einem monat gestimmt monarchie bis vor
einem monat
stimmt gar nicht das rohr strengen
zitronig zwischen einfachere die
mögliche schnittstellen möglich stumpel
behinderte die möglichst unbefangen was
direkt im august mit übersprungenen der
übersprang im zuge der die möglichst
überaus momeni hat das obwohl aber für
die schweizer klubteam übersee
weil es der politische weg und gibt im
klartext reden trotzdem ist es klappen
obwohl aber sicher spannend unter der
eines chemnitz wettskandal tätig
kenntnis sonnencreme ist voller härte
gegen die chemnitz ja dass chemnitz ots
chemnitz seine worte mit denen eine
etablierte deshalb eine antwort und zwar
mit ein wo mit ingram micro
ich habe darum bevorzugen muss chemnitz
ots chemnitz ots chemnitz nur für ihn
sondern erst in fleckenberg single miss
chemnitzer ist obwohl er vor im
augenblick zum angereist obwohl ab
sondern zog es vor bis dahin sorgen
machen
wieso man am liebsten geschenk machen
platz zwei war heiter bis ganzes machen
bis ganz machen ganz falsch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es nervt mich mega dass er im august
begonnen ihre langsamkeit beim shoppen
dass sie sich immer stress weil ich
meine haare zu verlassen
seine englische humor nervt manchmal
spontan habe ich nichts dazu
[Musik]